vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos
comparando los valores absolutos por
ejemplo digamos que nos preguntamos cómo
hacer la comparación entre el valor
absoluto de menos 9 o también conocido
como un 9 negativo como hacer la
comparación entre el valor absoluto de
él y el valor absoluto de algún otro
número que nos parezca interesante
digamos el número menos 7 o también 7
negativo
hay que pensar un poco y vamos a
imaginar cómo se verían los números
menos 9 y menos 7 en la recta numérica
veremos cuál es el valor absoluto y
luego podremos hacer la comparación
hay unas cuantas maneras en pensar una
serie dibujar una marca en donde debería
de ir el número en la recta numérica si
este es cero y este es el menos siete
entonces menos nueve ocupa este lugar
ahora cuando tomamos el valor absoluto
en realidad estamos observando qué tan
lejos está el número del cero este
podría estar a la izquierda del cero de
ser un número negativo o a la derecha
del cero de ser positivo por ejemplo
menos 9 está exactamente a 9 lugares a
la izquierda del 0 entonces su valor
absoluto es de 9 menos 7 está
exactamente a 7 lugares a la izquierda
del 0 es exactamente 7 lugares por lo
tanto su valor absoluto de 7 positivo si
ahora fuéramos a comparar 9 y 7 esto se
convierte en algo más directo claramente
9 es más grande que 7 si por alguna
razón que confundiera centre los signos
mayor que o menor que sólo recuerda que
el símbolo es más grande en el lado
izquierdo que justamente se trata del
lado mayor
si consideramos los números originales
tenemos que menos 9 en efecto es menor
que menos 7
hay que observar que el lado pequeño de
la desigualdad apunta donde se encuentra
el número más chico lo interesante es
que menos 9 es menor que menos 7 pero
sus valores absolutos no menos 9 está
más a la izquierda del 0 que menos 7 por
lo tanto su valor absoluto es mayor que
el de menos 7
otra manera de pensarlo es que al tomar
el valor absoluto de un número en
realidad es justo el número positivo de
él entonces si tomas el valor absoluto
de 9 este será igual a 9 o el valor
absoluto de menos 9 también es 9 cuando
lo ves de forma visual esto es porque
tanto 9 como menos 9 distan 9 espacios
del 0 9 del lado derecho y menos 9 del
lado izquierdo
hagamos unos ejemplos más digamos que
queremos comparar el valor absoluto de
un número positivo como el 2 con el
valor absoluto de 3 ambos son números
positivos por lo que su valor absoluto
está dado por el lugar que ocupan a la
derecha del ser de esta forma el valor
absoluto de dos es 2 y el valor absoluto
de 3 es 3 aquí es directo claramente el
número 2 es el menor 2 es menor que 3 y
por lo tanto el valor absoluto de 2 es
menor que el valor absoluto de 3 ahora
compararemos otro tipo de números
tomaremos números muy similares digamos
el valor absoluto de menos 8 lo
compararemos con valor absoluto de 8 una
manera de pensarlo sería que los dos
están a 8 lugares de distancia del
número 0 este menos 8 a la izquierda y 8
a la derecha ambos tienen un valor
absoluto de 8 valor absoluto de menos 8
es 8 valor absoluto de 8 es 8 y
claramente 8 es igual a 8 por lo cual
sus valores absolutos también hagamos un
último ejemplo digamos que deseo
comparar el valor absoluto de menos uno
y lo quiero comparar con un 2 positivo
de manera que el valor absoluto de menos
1 es sólo la versión positiva de menos 1
esto es vale 1
claramente uno es menor que 2 de otra
manera el valor absoluto de menos 1 es
claramente menor que 2